Montee ax is a crime victim someone
apparently snuck cameras into Kevin
Hart's private hotel suite in Las Vegas
and recorded bedroom images of the two
of them the woman allegedly at the
center of the Kevin Hart extortion
scandal speaks out
Monty Fogg and her attorney elisa bloom
held a press conference Wednesday she
had an intimate relationship with mr.
Hart about a month ago yes she does not
have any idea who's behind this it is a
crime to secretly put a camera in a
private place it is another crime to
secretly record people in a private
place Montoya is therefore the victim of
multiple felonies under state and
federal law although it has been
reported that law enforcement is
investigating this matter we have no
evidence of that Montoya has not been
contacted therefore we are announcing
today that we will go to the authorities
immediately to report this matter we
will fully cooperate with law
enforcement
Montoya and I are not asking for a cent
from Kevin Hart this is not about money
we are not suing him we are not making
any claims against him any reports to
the contrary are false Kevin Hart
appears to be the victim of this
criminal just as Montoya is the victim
of this criminal we invite mr. Hart to
join us in bringing the perpetrator to
justice to the criminal who did this
I say you belong in prison and we are
going to find you no comment from Hart
today though a source close to the actor
tells eg his team is quote just writing
out to the storm right now